Du würdest nicht in sein Helm ins Toilett gehen und dann es den Polizisten in die Widerung stehlen und dann es wieder stehlen. Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express Ausgabe Nummer 46. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und es geht weiter mit Chaosradio Express in deutlich schnellerer Folge, als wir das bisher gehabt haben. Und das ist auch gut so. Und heute geht es um ein komplexes Thema. Ein so komplexes Thema, dass allein schon der Begriff vieldeutig und mehrdeutig ist und von jedem so ausgelegt wird, wie er möchte. Und um diesen Phänomen ein bisschen auf die Spur zu kommen, habe ich mich heute mit Pavel zusammengetan. Hallo, Pavel.
Hallo, Tim.
Und wir wollen darüber reden und das Thema ist Sicherheit. Sicherlich eines der größten Gummivorte, die die deutsche Sprache jemals hervorgebracht hat. Findest du nicht auch?
Naja, also es hat auf jeden Fall extrem viele Facetten.
Ja, da gibt es zum Beispiel schon mal diese Standardverwechslung, was ja im Englischen so schön getrennt ist zwischen Safety und Security. Da werden wir sicherlich noch drauf eingehen. Aber ansonsten ist natürlich auch Sicherheit in der aktuellen politischen Diskussion der große Vorschlaghammer. Jeder hat immer so seine Argumente und meint halt, dass es zur Sicherheit beitragt. Und wir wollen jetzt hier im Gespräch ein wenig aufgeliedern, was man unter Sicherheit eigentlich verstehen kann, verstehen sollte und im Idealfall vielleicht auch welche Implikation das Ganze für uns alle haben kann. Du hast ja ein bisschen Gedanken gemacht. Wir haben schon ein paar Mal darüber gesprochen, aber noch nicht so richtig alles ausführlich gemacht, weil das haben wir uns schon vor Monaten vorgenommen. Das wollten wir dann doch mal in einen Podcast packen. Und so soll es nun auch sein. Ladies and Gentlemen, das Thema ist Sicherheit. Und meine erste Frage ist natürlich, Pavel, was ist eigentlich Sicherheit?
Tja, also Sicherheit ist ein Zustand zunächst mal und ein Zustand, der ja frei von unvertretbaren Risiken ist, von Gefahren. Man könnte auch ganz kurz sagen, Sicherheit ist, wenn man keine bösen Überraschungen erwartet und erwarten muss.
Wenn man es selbst nicht erwartet oder also wenn man glaubt, dass man, dass sie nicht kommen oder sicher sein kann, in Einflussstrichen, dass sie nicht kommen.
Nein, wenn man gut, da gibt es natürlich Sicherheit ist natürlich auch was Subjektives oder was Objektives. Also man kann natürlich zwischen gefühlter Sicherheit und realer Sicherheit auch noch unterscheiden oder muss es unterscheiden. Da werden wir sicherlich später auch noch mal drauf kommen. Aber ja, Sicherheit hat halt eben extrem viele Facetten, die sich durch alle Lebensbereiche durchziehen und durch Personen, also einzelne Individuen, aber auch ist ein gesellschaftliches Phänomen und auch ein technologisches Phänomen. Das heißt, Sicherheit, ja, die Frage Sicherheit betrifft eben Maschinen, Menschen, Staaten. Sie betrifft einfach alles. Und so, wenn wir uns jetzt mal zunächst mal auf Mensch und Gesellschaft und Sicherheit konzentrieren, gibt es ganz schön den Begriff der öffentlichen Sicherheit, der ja häufig so hoch gehalten wird als eines der höchsten Sicherheits… Das klinge aber irgendwie… klinge ich sehr leise.
Du klingst leise? Dann müssen wir mal deinen Kanal ein bisschen hochdrehen. Du kannst einfach weitermachen. Ich mach dich ein bisschen lauter.
Vielleicht muss ich das Mikro auch noch etwas anders positionieren.
Besser?
Gut, das ist etwas besser. Das Thema öffentliche Sicherheit ist eine Erfindung, die noch gar nicht so alt ist, der sich auch das Bundesverfassungsgericht gelegentlich bedient. Und das meint so Schutz zentraler Rechtsgüter, wie es so schön heißt, Leben, Gesundheit, Freiheit, aber auch Ehre, Eigentum und Vermögen. Interessant ist es eben an der Stelle auch der Schutz der Freiheit natürlich, ein Sicherheitsaspekt ist und zwar sowohl des Einzelnen, aber auch öffentliche Sicherheit, ja meint auch und so wird es gerne dann von den Politikern interpretiert, die Unversehrtheit der Rechtsordnung und der staatlichen Einrichtung. Also wenn es ja gegen den Staat geht, ist eben auch die öffentliche Sicherheit.
Aber ist das nicht das, was man normalerweise unter der Diskussion der inneren Sicherheit versteht?
Ja, innere Sicherheit ist natürlich Teil auch der öffentlichen Sicherheit, ist aber beschränkter. Das heißt, innere Sicherheit ist vor allem, ja so schön heißt es, der Schutz von Staat und Gesellschaft, hauptsächlich vor Kriminalität und Terrorismus, aber von Gefahren, die vor allem aus dem Innern der Gesellschaft herauskommen. Das heißt, Angriffe von Nachbarn oder anderen Staaten sind eigentlich Teil der äußeren Sicherheit. Das heißt, so ein Phänomen wie Terrorismus, was hochgehalten wird, betrifft dann natürlich sowohl die innere als auch die äußere Sicherheit, je nachdem, wo die Terroristen gerade herkommen.
Okay, aber ich sehe ehrlich gesagt jetzt noch keinen wirklich entscheidenden großen Unterschied zwischen diesen beiden Begriffen. Also, warum findest du, dass man das noch auseinanderklamm büsern muss?
Die innere und die äußere Sicherheit oder die öffentliche und die innere? Naja, bei der öffentlichen Sicherheit, die ist etwas deutlich abstrakteres und hat auch, also es ist auch eine rechtshistorische Geschichte und wird von der sogenannten öffentlichen Ordnung auch abgeleitet. Und das hat mal ein preußisches Oberverwaltungsgericht abgeleitet seinerzeit aus der öffentlichen Ordnung. Das heißt, öffentliche Sicherheit ist halt Erhalt der öffentlichen Ordnung. Und es ist eben eine ganz übergeordnete Geschichte, die halt innere und äußere Sicherheit mit einbezieht. Aber ich denke, das sind auch bisweilen Spitzfindigkeiten interessanter, finde ich, das Thema individuelle Sicherheit daneben, die ja auch wiederum Teil der inneren und äußeren Sicherheit und der öffentlichen Sicherheit ist. Und da finde ich ganz bemerkenswert an der aktuellen Sicherheitsdiskussion, dass dort, wenn man von Sicherheit redet, oft ein ganz wichtiger Aspekt der individuellen Sicherheit offenbar ausgeklammert wird. Nämlich einmal ist individuelle Sicherheit natürlich so die unmittelbare körperliche Unversehrtheit und Bedrohungsfreiheit. Aber was auch zur individuellen Sicherheit natürlich gehört, ist die dauerhafte Gewährleistung der existenziellen Basis. Das heißt, es ist nicht nur eine Frage der Sicherheit, dass ich gerade nicht von jemandem überfallen oder erschlagen werde, sondern auch, dass ich nicht Angst davor haben muss, zu verhungern oder zu erfrieren. Das hat auf jeden Fall auch denselben Stellenwert für das Individuum. Aber nicht in der öffentlichen Diskussion. Da wird das Thema Sicherheit ganz gerne reduziert oder fokussiert im Augenblick auf die körperliche Unversehrtheit.
Das ist schon so ein bisschen absurd in der öffentlichen Diskussion. Wenn jetzt jemand vom Terroristen erschossen wird, dann ist das drei Wochen lang die große Nachricht. Aber wenn ein Obdachloser im Garten erfriert, dann redet da eigentlich kein Mensch drum. Dann ist es so, schade, tut uns leid. Dabei sollte es eigentlich denselben Status besitzen.
Dann gibt es natürlich auch noch den schönen Begriff der Rechtssicherheit, um das Spektrum mal noch weiter aufzuspannen. Dabei geht es darum, dass staatliche Entscheidungen klar bestimmt und beständig sind. Das heißt, dass man sich auch darauf verlassen kann, auch vor bösen Überraschungen, die von der Seite des Staates kommen, geschützt zu sein, also auch vor Willkür oder vor nachträglicher Änderung von Rechtsnormen. Und auch da ist bedauerlicherweise eine Verschiebung zu sehen, wo auch zunehmend mehr Rechtssicherheit, ja, abstrakten Bedrohungen zum Opfer fällt, wie wir ja an der Verkomplizierung von Gesetzen, das ist eigentlich ein weltweites Phänomen, dass halt in großer Eile Paragrafen geschaffen werden, die nicht ordentlich durchdacht sind, wo man jetzt nicht weiß, darf ich das jetzt, ist es vielleicht verboten so.
Aber wir brauchen das jetzt und deswegen müssen wir das jetzt ganz schnell haben.
Ja, und das betrifft nun auch alle möglichen Menschen, also auch gerade die, die jetzt wirtschaftlich agieren, beispielsweise, gut, das ist eh schon ein geflügeltes Wort, dass man so in Deutschland als Geschäftsführer eines Unternehmens immer mit einem Bein im Gefängnis steht, weil man gar nicht überblicken kann, was es so an Rechtsnormen alles gibt, in denen man sich vielleicht verstricken oder verheddern kann. Das ist ehrlich auch ein großes Problem. Ja, und um jetzt den ersten Rundumschlag vielleicht mal noch vollständig zu machen, vielleicht noch ein kurzer Blick auf das Thema technische Sicherheit, was auch dazu gehört. Und wie wir alle wissen, bei technischen Einrichtungen wird gerne viel Energie umgesetzt. Und Technik ist in allen Lebensbereichen mittlerweile vertreten. Und wenn da was schiefgeht, kann das natürlich auch gravierende Folgen haben.
Das ist ja das, was der englische Begriff Safety abdeckt im Prinzip.
Ja, kann man kann man so sagen, wobei dort auch dann wieder Security natürlich auch mit reinspielt. Aber es ist richtig im Wesentlichen ist, die technische Sicherheit ist das, was man als Safety bezeichnet. Und da ist es ist es auch faszinierend, in wie viele Aspekte das Ganze rein geht oder wie geregelt das Ganze ist. Es fängt an durch was geregelt durch Gesetze durch durch Gesetze und durch Organe, die sich um alle möglichen Sicherheitsaspekte kümmern und Vorschriften vor allem.
Bevor wir da rein hüpfen, noch mal eine Frage zu den restlichen Sicherheitsdefinitionen, die wir jetzt durchgegangen sind. Öffentliche innere Sicherheit und Schutze der Personen. Woraus leitest du jetzt deine Betrachtung ab? Ist das im Prinzip jetzt so die Verfassung der Bundesrepublik Deutschland, der Rechtskonsens der Gerichte hierzulande? Oder siehst du da auch so ein globales Einverständnis, dass das anerkannte Prinzipien sind?
Ja, das ist so ein bisschen so, wie sich das, also ein bisschen eine enzyklopädische Sicht natürlich auf die Dinge, wie sich die Begriffe so im allgemeinen Sprachgebrauch entwickelt haben. Aber dem stehen natürlich dann überall auch Rechtsnormen entgegen oder Organisationen, die sich darum gründen. Oder Wissenschaften, also ja, das sind so die Themen oder Bezeichnungen, die aus meiner Sicht die wichtigsten sind, wenn es um Sicherheit geht, die Zweige oder Aspekte von Sicherheit.
Na dann tauchen wir noch mal kurz hier in die Technik ein.
Kurz in die technische Sicherheit, ja. Also Arbeitssicherheit, so ein großes Thema in jeder größeren Firma, gibt es einen Sicherheitsbeauftragten. Genau, Helme, Schuhe mit Stahlkappen ist sicherlich so ein Ding. Aber auch alle möglichen Aspekte, Sicherheit an Maschinen, dass einem nicht irgendwo versehentlich der Arm oder die Haare irgendwo hinein geraten und viele andere Dinge.
Dann natürlich diese Kreissäge, die sich sofort runterschnappt, wenn irgendwie... Wie heißt das Ding noch gleich?
Ziemlich nettes Gerät auf jeden Fall. Das funktioniert elektrisch.
Genau, und wenn man so eine Gurke ranhält, dann schnappt das Ding sofort weg. Und das soll angeblich auch mit dem Arm funktionieren.
Ja, sobald man mit einem Körperteil irgendwie das Sägeblatt berührt, zieht sich das Sägeblatt in Millisekunden, also ich glaube, in weniger als einer Millisekunde verschwindet.
Das ist echt beeindruckend, diese Demo-Videos, wo dann so diese Gurke, die sie da so zum Test reinschieben, so ein ganz kleines Äckchen weggesägt ist.
Das ist sehr nett. Dann gibt es natürlich den großen Komplex Verkehrssicherheit, worunter dann natürlich der etwas technische Aspekt wie der Fahrzeugsicherheit, der allseits bekannte TÜV, der dafür sorgt, aber auch so Dinge wie Straßenverkehrszulassungsordnung. Dann großes Thema natürlich Flugsicherheit, auch mit allen möglichen Aspekten, wo wir vielleicht später auch noch mal drauf kommen. Interessanterweise zählt aber auch Umweltschutz zur technischen Sicherheit, weil da wird dann in dem Fall nicht der Mensch, sondern die gesamte Umwelt, also auch ein Lebensbereich mit anderen Organismen und Tieren und Lebewesen geschützt. Medikamentensicherheit, ein riesengroßes Thema. Lebensmittelsicherheit, wo wenig drüber geredet wird, wo sicherlich auch durchaus Bedrohungen da sind. Dann Reaktorsicherheit, auch ein ganz wichtiger Punkt in der öffentlichen Diskussion. Zumindest, obwohl es nur relativ wenig Reaktoren gibt und relativ wenig Menschen jetzt nun drin arbeiten oder jedes jeweils so etwas.
Aber wenn einer halt nicht sicher ist, dann ist das auch gleich der große Faktor ab.
Ja, und das zeigt halt, dass die Größe dieses Themas zeigt offenbar, ja, dass Schadenshöhe dort erheblich sein kann. Und dann natürlich der ganze große Bereich der Informationssicherheit, der sich dann wiederum in Datensicherheit, Computersicherheit und Netzwerksicherheit.
Jetzt sind wir aber bei Security und nicht mehr bei Safety, oder?
Ja, aber wir sind ja, es ist ja eine deutschsprachige Sendung und insofern fällt das.
Okay, aber vorhin hat man ja gesagt, so naja, technische Sicherheit, das ist jetzt irgendwie das, was man unter Safety versteht. Wenn man das jetzt wieder reinmischen sollte, kann man es noch auseinanderbessern.
Ja, also bei der Informationssicherheit treffen diese Dinge aber auch wieder Security und Safety natürlich wieder aufeinander. Beziehungsweise da kommen beide Aspekte mit rein, weil sowohl jetzt Sicherheit, also beim Begriff jetzt Datensicherheit etwa, geht es nun auch darum, dass die Daten entweder verloren gehen können, verfälscht werden können, aus technischen Gründen, aber natürlich auch wiederum in falsche Hände gelangen oder anderweitig missbraucht werden können. Aber das ist auf jeden Fall auch ein großer Komplex.
Was war für dich jetzt der Anlass, mal darüber nachzudenken, Sicherheit so aufzublättern und in seine Bestandteile zu zerlegen?
Der Ausgangspunkt war, dass ich damit konfrontiert wurde, doch mal was Konstruktives zum Thema Sicherheit beizutragen beziehungsweise mir die Möglichkeit eröffnet wurde. Es gibt bestimmte Projekte, an denen ich möglicherweise teilnehmen kann und wo ich halt aber selbst in einem gewissen Rahmen die Freiheit hatte zu definieren, was ich denn nun zu diesem Thema Sicherheit konstruktiv beitragen kann. Das war erstmal eigentlich ein ganz interessanter oder ein großes Problem erstmal, weil natürlich in seinem persönlichen Bereich und Umfeld kümmert man sich selten explizit um Sicherheit, sondern das läuft alles irgendwo nebenher. Aber wenn man jetzt nun aufgefordert ist oder die Möglichkeit hat, nun was zu tun, stellte sich natürlich die Frage, was wäre sinnvoll zu tun. Weil eigentlich ist Sicherheit schon durchaus jedermanns Anliegen. Leider hatte ich aber den Eindruck, dass jetzt durch der Begriff der Sicherheit auch massiv diskreditiert worden ist. In meinen Augen durch viele komplett sinnlose und überbordende Sicherheitsmaßnahmen und Einschränkungen der Freiheit, die im Namen der Sicherheit getätigt wurden, Gewalttaten, die verübt worden sind, um irgendwo vermeintlich für mehr Sicherheit in der Welt zu sagen. Das heißt eigentlich etwas, was mir durchaus auch am Herzen liegt. Sicherheit, einen Begriff habe ich plötzlich begonnen und das fiel mir aber an der Stelle erst auf, dass ich irgendwie das Thema, dass ich Sicherheit überhaupt nicht mehr hören konnte. Und dann sozusagen in dieser Situation dann auch noch ja etwas zu tun oder vorzuschlagen, was man denn zur Verbesserung der Sicherheit machen kann. Das erforderte dann doch erst mal ein etwas breiteres Ausholen, um zu gucken, okay, was.
Okay, erst mal die Analyse und dann sozusagen die Konsequenzen. Aber bei der Analyse sind wir noch.
Und genau, was?
Ja, dabei habe ich dich unterbrochen.
Ich wollte nur erwähnen, warum ich jetzt speziell auch in die technische Sicherheit noch mal reingeguckt habe, weil ich habe nun einen sehr wissenschafts- und techniklastigen Hintergrund und manchmal ist es sehr hilfreich, so in die technische Domäne hineinzuschauen und zu gucken, wie geht man dort mit Sicherheitsfragen um und gibt es vielleicht Möglichkeiten, so aus einer Sicherheitsdomäne etwas in die andere zu übertragen an Prinzipien oder an Ideen oder Gedanken. Das ist oft ein ganz gutes Vorgehen, habe ich gemerkt, wenn man nicht weiß, so oder irgendwo jetzt Innovationen auf Knopfdruck liefern soll, dass man sich dann erstmal verwandte Domänen anschaut, weil es laufen eben auf dieser Welt sehr viele Experten herum, die immer nur in ein Gebiet hineingucken und andere, die in einem anderen Gebiet unterwegs sind und keiner schaut mal über den Tellerrand. Dabei lassen sich so gerade ganz, ganz wertvolle neue Ideen entwickeln und das war der Hintergrund, dass ich mir auch mal die grundlegenden Prinzipien technischer Sicherheit beispielsweise angeschaut habe auf etwas abstrakterer Ebene.
Also der Blick über den Tellerrand. Was sieht man da, wenn man sich mal aus der Schüssel herausbequemt?
Wenn man zunächst mal anguckt bei der technischen Sicherheit, unterscheidet man jetzt auch wieder in der Forschung und auch teilweise in den Gesetzen die unmittelbare, mittelbare und hinweisende Sicherheit. Die unmittelbare Sicherheit soll technisch verhindern, dass Gefahren überhaupt entstehen. Da gehen wir gleich nochmal aus. Indem man die Geräte beispielsweise so baut, dass sie einfach sicher sind oder sie vielleicht gar nicht baut. So bestimmte Stoffe vielleicht gar nicht verwendet. Also unmittelbare Sicherheit heißt dann auch so ein bisschen eventuell Verzicht, aber auch Redundanzkontrolle. Bei der Mittelbahnsicherheit weiß man, okay, da ist etwas, das ist gefährlich. Um aber das im Griff zu behalten, brauche ich zusätzliche Sicherheitseinrichtungen. Ich baue also etwas drumrum, etwas, also ich sorge für Sicherheit durch etwas Äußeres. Also die Gefahr ist da und ich versuche sie gewissermaßen einzudämmen.
Wenn man vom Seil fällt, fällt man ins Netz.
Oder explosionssichere Gehäuse, bei Kernkraftwerken halt der große Betonbehälter, die die Panzerung ist zum Beispiel, ein Beispiel für mittelbare Sicherheit, indem man einfach dicke Mauern drumrum baut, aber auch Auslaufwannen für Batterie, Räume und so weiter. Ja, ähnliche Dinge. Und dann auch noch der schwächste Bereich jetzt von Sicherheit, oder der am wenigsten mit Technik zu tun hat, aber auch natürlich ganz wichtig ist es einfach die hinweisende Sicherheit. Das heißt, man bringt ein Warnschild an, Achtung. Knopfdrücken verboten. Genau. Keine Hamster und Katzen in der Mikrowelle trocknen. Das heißt, man macht jetzt keinen Katzendetektor.
Das dient aber, glaube ich, mit der Rechtssicherheit der Mikrowellen-Gerätehersteller.
Aber generell, also Verfahrensvorschriften, wie geht man mit den Dingen um, damit es sicher bleibt. Oder auffallende Markierungen an Treppenstufen, über die man…
Aber am besten ist es ja eigentlich, dass man dieser unmittelbaren Sicherheitsvorschub leistet, dass man überhaupt erstmal verhindert, dass überhaupt irgendwas passiert.
Ja, also das ist natürlich die sicherste Variante, wenn Systeme unmittelbar sicher sind. Und da gibt es dann auch wieder drei Möglichkeiten oder Verfahren, wie man solche unmittelbare Sicherheit herstellen kann. Das eine ist der sogenannte Safe Life Ansatz. Und da versucht man sämtliche äußeren Einflüsse zu klären und dadurch das Versagen auszuschließen. Das heißt beispielsweise, wenn ich einen Damm baue, dann versuche ich halt rauszufinden, wie viel Wasser kommt da an und wie fest ist der Untergrund. Und ja, ich bemesse einfach das Ganze.
Ein Tank muss genug Sprit aufnehmen, damit die Maschine lang genug durchlaufen kann, wenn keine Sprit kommt.
Oder jetzt nehmen wir mal einen Brückenbau, einfach, dass sich dort eine vernünftige Statik, dass ich weiß, okay, welche Windkräfte können auftreten, was ist mit Erdbeben, wie viele Fahrzeuge, von welchem Gewicht werden nun da drauffahren. Also sämtliche äußeren Einflüsse, die dort einwirken können, dem ich die kläre und dann meine Technologie so bemesse, dass sie halt dem Stand hält. Und was ich aber dann auch tun muss, um das zu gewährleisten, ist eben fortlaufende Kontrolle, was jetzt in den USA offenbar auch nicht funktioniert hat, als die Brücke eingestürzt ist, dass man nämlich guckt, rostet das jetzt vielleicht vor sich hin, läuft da irgendwas aus dem Ruder, treten dort Überlastungen auf. Also Klärung von äußeren Einflüssen, sicheres Bemessen und fortlaufende Kontrolle ist so der Safe-Life-Ansatz, der halt viel gefahren wird.
Das ist ein interessanter Punkt, dass du das ansprichst, dieser Zusammenbruch großer öffentlicher Infrastrukturen, also was man in den USA gesehen hat, auch vorher in England schon, so das Bahnsystem, was sie jahrelang haben verkommen lassen, bringt ja dann auch in der Summe am Ende viel mehr Kosten für den Einzelnen mit sich, weil in New York sind jetzt auch die Dampfleitungen explodiert. Also abgesehen davon, dass Leute dabei gestorben sind und das schon mal so eine Gefahr darstellt, fragt man sich halt auch, warum in aller Welt gibt es in New York überhaupt noch Dampfleitungen. Also da ist wahrscheinlich auch so der Erneuerungszyklus irgendwann vollkommen eingerostet. Das bittet sicherlich auch noch mal eine Gefahrenquelle an.
Gut, da kommen wir vielleicht auch noch mal später drauf, wenn wir gucken, was das so psychologisch, politisch und betriebswirtschaftlich, wie dort das Thema Sicherheit gesehen wird und welche Probleme da sind. Vielleicht machen wir kurz noch, bevor wir es komplett vergessen, noch die anderen beiden, also bei der unmittelbaren Sicherheit den Safe-Life-Ansatz hatten. Denn was sicherlich auch jeder schon mal gehört hat, ist das Thema Failsafe. Failsafe bedeutet, dass wenn etwas schief geht, dass dann der sogenannte Failure Mode, wie man das nennt, also was passiert, dass man den so gestaltet, dass eine gefahrlose Außerbetriebnahme beispielsweise erfolgt. Also ein Beispiel etwa sind Lkw-Bremsen. Lkw-Bremsen funktionieren ja über ein Druckluftsystem mit einem Kompressor. Und jetzt kann es natürlich passieren, dass die Luft, dass der Kompressor ausfällt oder durch eine Undichtigkeit im Druckluftsystem plötzlich keine Druckluft mehr zur Verfügung steht. Und deswegen operieren Lkw-Bremsen eben auch so, dass dort durch die Druckluft, zumindest Teile der Bremsen, nicht etwa auf die Bremsklötze gedrückt werden, sondern eine starke Feder vom Bremsklotz weggedrückt wird. Das heißt, wenn dort jetzt etwa ein Schlauch platzt beispielsweise oder abreißt, dann führt das zu einer Bremsung. Das ist ein Beispiel für ein Failsafe-Mechanismus.
Das heißt, dann wird automatisch die Feder nicht mehr zurückgehalten.
Genau.
Das heißt, ein Teil der Bremsenergie geht immer sozusagen zur aufrechter Haltung dieses Failsafe-Systems. Und in dem Moment, wo es failt, springt das dann los.
Bei Zügen, bei Zugbremsen gibt es da auch etwa ähnliche Mechanismen. Oder jetzt im Bereich auch elektrische Systeme. Oder wenn wir mal jetzt kurz in Web-Technologie oder Sicherheitstechnologie im Netz gehen, da ist natürlich ein entsprechender Ansatz, dass wenn etwa eine Authentifizierung fehlschlägt oder irgendein Sicherheitsprogramm versagt, dass ein Fehler auftritt, dass man dann keinen Zugang gewährt, statt das Programm versagt und das Sicherheitsprogramm versagt. Ich bekomme deswegen vollen Zugang, was, wenn das nicht beachtet wird, gelegentlich auch der Fall ist oder zu Fehlern führt. Deswegen sind dann auch bestimmte Systeme, die etwa die Authentifizierung prüfen. In der Regel werden, wenn mehrere Prüfungen nacheinander stattfinden, eben auch in so einem Failsafe-Mode betrieben. Und das letzte Prinzip ist Redundanz, um für unmittelbare Sicherheit zu sagen, indem man Teile mehrfach auslegt, sodass die Gesamtfunktion erhalten bleibt, auch wenn einzelne Teile ausfallen. Das kennt man auch beim Auto. Da hat man eben nicht nur einen Bremskreislauf, sondern getrennte Bremskreisläufe wiederum für. In der Regel ist es so, dass das rechte Vorderrad und das linke Hinterrad umgekehrt jeweils an einem Bremskreislauf hängen, wenn der ausfällt.
Dass man zumindest noch vorne und hinten und auch links und rechts in irgendeiner Form Bremsung hat, dass es nicht einseitig ist.
Oder natürlich in der Luftfahrt spielt das eine ganz wichtige Rolle. Die Qualität moderner Düsen-Triebwerke ist jetzt so weit, dass man auch mittlerweile mit zwei strahligen Flugzeugen über den Atlantik fliegt. Aber eine lange Zeit, wo man wählt, da immer noch mit zwei strahligen Flugzeugen eine Flugroute, die etwas nördlicher liegt, wo man dann jeweils Notflugplätze in der Nähe hat, für den Fall, dass das zweite Triebwerk nun auch ausfallen sollte. Aber lange Zeit waren deswegen die 747 als vierstrahliger Jet ausgelegt. Tatsächlich auch aus dem Grunde, um bei Versagen eines Triebwerks dennoch weiterfliegen zu können. Das ist auch ein Beispiel für Redundanz.
Oder bei Computern auch ganz populär halt Raid-Systeme, wenn man jetzt Festplatten hat, wo man eben sichere Daten drauf haben möchte. Dann gibt es halt immer noch eine Platte, die einspringt. Daten werden doppelt gespeichert.
Oder im Speicher zusätzliche Parity-Bits oder Fehler korrigierender Speicher, wo man eben auch dafür ein bisschen mehr Information speichert, um in dem Fall, wenn irgendwo mal Information zerstört wird, die rekonstruieren zu können.
Ich denke, das wird auch immer wichtiger, weil in zunehmendem Maße, wo Computer eben wichtige Funktionen übernehmen und Datenverlust einfach mal tödlich ist, auch zur Laufzeit, nicht nur in solchen Massen speichern, gibt es eigentlich so Hauptspeicher, der wirklich so richtig wie Fehler korrigiert ist in dieser Fehler Korrektur.
Typischerweise, also es gibt, der ist glaube ich ziemlich aus der Mode gekommen, also es gibt einmal Speicher, wo man zu 8-Bit jeweils ein Parity-Bit noch dazu hat. Damit kann man nur Bitfehler erkennen. Und mit 3-Bit zusätzlichen, also mit 2, ja doch mit 3-Bit ist es möglich, beliebige Bitfehler zu korrigieren.
Wenn es aber am einen Bit ist.
Also wenn ein Bit falsch ist, wird das erkannt. Genau, wenn ein Bit umkippt, so dann, ja.
Weiß man welches.
Weiß man welches und kann es wieder.
Muss die Software dann darauf reagieren?
Nein, das passiert vollständig im Bus-System, der Speicherkontroller macht das selbst. Wird sicherlich auch in der Zukunft eine größere Rolle spielen, wenn Systeme immer schneller werden, immer näher an die physikalischen Grenzen herankommt, wird es irgendwann billiger in Kauf zu nehmen, dass die Systeme einfach Fehler machen und sie stattdessen eben Fehler korrigieren auszulegen. Ja, von mir aus können wir jetzt wieder von der Technik wegschwenken und nochmal das Thema Sicherheit jetzt mal aus politischer Sicht.
Sicherheit und die Gesellschaft und vor allem das Verhältnis des Staates zur Sicherheit.
Ja, also erstmal Sicherheit, ich sag Sicherheit erstmal aus politischer Sicht, was vielleicht...
Die Frage, wer nimmt eigentlich Sicherheit tatsächlich wahr?
Wer welche Sicherheitsaufgaben am besten wahrnehmen soll und kann. Aber vielleicht gucken wir mal erst mal generell, wie die politische Sicht auf Sicherheit eigentlich aussieht. Und was da eigentlich völlig klar sein sollte, aber was in der momentanen Debatte auch offenbar oft aus dem Blick gerät, ist, dass der Staat keinesfalls für totale Sicherheit sorgen kann. Also gutes Beispiel, ich muss mein Haus selbst mit verschließbaren Türen sichern, weil der Staat nicht vor die Tür eines Einzelnen einen Polizisten stellen kann, um dafür zu sorgen, dass da niemand Falsches reinkommt. Das heißt, der Staat kann tatsächlich nur punktuell wirklich Sicherheit gewährleisten. Und auf gar keinen Fall, also es ist einfach praktisch technisch nicht möglich.
Das ist doch nicht seine Aufgabe an der Stelle, oder?
Nein. Das heißt, das Problem ist wiederum, dass viele Formen von Sicherheit dann doch nur durch staatliche Organisationen oder durch größere Organisationen gewährleistet werden können. Also wenn wir doch mal gucken, also zum Beispiel äußere Sicherheit. Also wir beide, die hier sitzen, wenn jetzt die Chinesen kommen, so da können wir beide privat erstmal relativ wenig gegentun. Das heißt, da muss es schon etwas geben. Also gegenüber anderen Staaten ganz klar kann man sich auch wiederum nur als Staat dem etwas entgegenzusetzen. Das heißt, äußere Sicherheit, denke ich, ist ganz klar eine Sache, die durch den Staat gewährleistet werden muss. Bei der nach inneren Sicherheit ist es ähnlich. Wobei, ja, und an den Stellen kommen dann vielleicht auch wieder die Unterscheidungen innere Sicherheit, öffentliche Sicherheit ins Spiel. Also die öffentliche Sicherheit, wiederum, kann der Staat eben alleine nicht gewährleisten. Das geht nur gemeinsam mit Bürgern und Unternehmen. Aber jetzt gewissermaßen, ja, Schutz. Letzten Endes vor Verbrechen, so durch das Gewaltmonopol, kann auch eigentlich nur durch den Staat gewährleistet werden. Natürlich gibt es zunehmend leider auch private Sicherheitsdienste, aber die sind, also wenn man jetzt innere Sicherheit als etwas großes Gesamtes betrachtet, kann jetzt ein privater Sicherheitsdienst nicht für innere Sicherheit sorgen, sondern...
Also zumindest nicht vor Terroristenschützern.
Und dann natürlich Rechtssicherheit kann auch nur der Staat gewährleisten. Und wie man dann auch sehen wird, wenn man nachher mal auf Sicherheit aus betriebswirtschaftlicher Sicht kommt, auch so Mindeststandards bei technischer Sicherheit kann auch nur der Staat durchsetzen und vorschreiben, weil von sich aus Sicherheit kostet Geld und...
Das ist dann der Maßstab, ja.
Das ist, ja.
Und dann hab ich mal aus Bankenkreisen diesen schönen Begriff gehört, der rentablen Sicherheit. Das ist sozusagen der Threshold. Man führt halt ein gewisse Sicherheitsminimum erst in dem Moment ein, wo es sich eben auch rentiert, also wo sozusagen der Schaden des Kunden noch nicht groß genug ist, um zu rechtfertigen, dass man da etwas unternimmt, weil das kann man dann schon verkraften.
Nee, ganz klar.
Also Sicherheit. Kreditkarten zum Beispiel.
Also Sicherheit unterliegt. Man könnte da gerne mal in dieses Thema reinspringen. Ich mein, Fakt ist, Sicherheitsmaßnahmen kosten einfach Geld und tragen nicht messbar zum Betriebsergebnis bei. Das ist so ein Kernproblem, weil das Geld muss erst mal ausgegeben werden für zusätzliche Redundanz oder Sicherheit.
Also steht das jetzt quasi die Perspektive einer Firma, die jetzt irgendwie Sicherheitsmaßnahmen machen muss?
Aus betriebswirtschaftlicher Sicht ist es eben so. Du hast halt zunächst mal Kosten. Aber das, was du gewinnst oder das, was vielleicht an Katastrophen nicht eingetreten ist, ist nicht zu beziffern. Das heißt, man kann nur genau angeben, wie viel es gekostet hat, für Sicherheit zu sorgen. Aber man hat nicht den Vergleichsmaßstab, wie viel hätte es gekostet, wenn diese Maßnahmen nicht da gewesen wären. Insofern ist es immer eine Sache, wo man niemals den Nachweis führen kann, dass diese Sicherheitsmaßnahmen jetzt notwendig oder gerechtfertigt sind.
So wie Krankenversicherung im Prinzip.
Ja, da geht das. Aber das andere Ding, weswegen, also aus betriebswirtschaftlicher Sicht, das ist auch eine psychologische Geschichte, Sicherheitsmaßnahmen sind lästig in jeder Hinsicht. Also sie verlangsamen Arbeitsprozesse. Das fängt an, wenn ich morgens die Alarmanlage ausschalten oder einschalten muss und bis hinten zu allen möglichen Ausweißsystemen, die ich vielleicht habe, oder komplizierte Kennwörter, die sich dauernd ändern. Oder wenn ich mit Verschlüsselung, also die Sicherheit ist lästig. Das ist glaube ich relativ...
Es kostet auch Zeit. Aufwand, man muss überhaupt darüber nachdenken, was zu tun ist.
Und wenn man mal jetzt etwa, also Gegenteil von Sicherheit, ist das die Anwesenheit von Risiken. Und Risiken betriebswirtschaftlich betrachtet in einer Risikoanalyse werden als Eintrittswahrscheinlichkeit mal Schadenshöhe berechnet. Das ist eine ganz einfache Rechnung, die man durchführen kann. So man guckt, was ist, wenn dieses... Also wie hoch ist das Risiko, was ich trage? Und das ist diese amortisierte Sicherheit, wenn irgendwo mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit von, sagen wir mal, 50 Prozent ein Schaden von 100.000 Euro eintrifft, dann habe ich ein Risiko in dem Moment, was ich mit 50.000 Euro bewerten kann. Das heißt, eine Versicherung, wenn man mal so rechnet. Es würde sich lohnen, 50.000 Euro für eine Versicherung auszugeben in diesem Fall. Und ja, und das lohnt sich, dass auch diese Betrachtung macht es tatsächlich einfacher, mit Risiken umzugehen, indem man sich wirklich anschaut, was kann im schlimmsten Fall passieren und wie wahrscheinlich ist es, dass es passiert. Und die Wahrscheinlichkeit kriegt man, indem man halt am einfachsten, indem man guckt, wenn es eine Historie gibt, wie häufig ist es in der Vergangenheit passiert oder wie häufig passieren die Dinge.
Und das ist jetzt eigentlich wirklich eine, reden wir jetzt wirklich von einer mathematischen Formel. Ja. Dabei, und was sind dann sozusagen die Einheiten, mit denen man Risiko bemisst? Also ist das jetzt alles nur Geld oder ist das reine Wahrscheinlichkeit?
Risiko ist Geld und Eintrittswahrscheinlichkeit ist eine dimensionslose Größe, die sich zwischen 0 und 1 bewegen kann.
Okay, und die Schadenszüge ist natürlich auch Geld.
Schadenszüge ist Geld letztendlich. Ja, und man kann jetzt auch, wenn man das Risiko vermindern will, kann man natürlich an diesen beiden Dingen auch ansetzen, betriebswirtschaftlich. Das heißt, entweder man versucht, die Eintrittswahrscheinlichkeit zu verringern, dass eben auch, ja, da kommt dann eine Analogie zu unserer unmittelbaren Sicherheit, nämlich dass man die äußeren Einflüsse klärt, dass man die Betriebsmittel sicher bemisst und dass man fortlaufend kontrolliert. Damit minimiert man die Eintrittswahrscheinlichkeit und umgekehrt die Schadenshöhe. Wenn man jetzt sagt, okay, es lohnt sich eventuell nicht, die Eintrittswahrscheinlichkeit zu minimieren, weil sie bereits entweder so gering ist, da spricht man vom sogenannten Restrisiko, dass halt weitere Minimierung nicht mehr vernünftig erscheint, dann geht man in die Schadenshöhe. Also Beispiel jetzt um das Risiko, dass mir meine Wohnung ausgeräumt wird oder abbrennt, könnte ich natürlich, wenn ich die Eintrittswahrscheinlichkeit verringern will, könnte ich mir eine zehn Zentimeter dicke Stahltür und überall Gitter vor die Fenster machen. Wenn ich das aber nicht will oder mir das übertrieben erscheint, dann greife ich zum Beispiel zu einer Versicherung oder ich versuche dann auch die Schadenshöhe zu minimieren, indem ich zu Hause nicht so viel Geld rumliegen lasse oder halt meine Backups nicht zu Hause lagere, sondern woanders oder im Falle jetzt von Bränden, dass man ja, wie es so schön heißt, kompartamentalisierung, das heißt ich habe im Brandfall etwa Brandabschnitte, Brandwände, das heißt das Feuer kann sich nicht weiter ausbreiten, daher kommt ja auch der Begriff der Firewall, die wiederum verhindern soll, dass Eindringlinge oder böse Wichte dort gestoppt werden und ja oder bei Schiffen eben wenn die dann mal leck schlagen, dass es dort einzelne Schotten gibt, sodass nicht mein ganzes Schiff voll läuft oder überhaupt mehrere Wände, Ja, das ist ein Thema, der eben gering. Ist. Aus betriebswirtschaftlicher Sicht Risiken vollständig ignoriert werden. Man sagt, okay, das ist sowas von unwahrscheinlich, weil man auch praktisch eben bei geringen Eintrittswahrscheinlichkeiten einfach nichts dagegen tun kann. Und interessanterweise werden aber genau solche Szenarien wieder, die man auch als Movieplot-Szenarien gerne bezeichnet, die eine extrem geringe Wahrscheinlichkeit haben, aber eine extrem große Schadenshöhe aufweisen. Die eignen sich wiederum hervorragend, um alles Mögliche zu rechtfertigen, weil eine extrem geringe, bei einer extrem geringen Eintritts-Verscheinlichkeit hat man nicht wirklich noch eine rationale Ansatzmöglichkeit, um diese Eintritts-Verscheinlichkeit weiter zu reduzieren. Das heißt, man kann letztendlich alles damit rechtfertigen mit der extrem hohen Schadenshöhe. Und fatalerweise ist ja mit 9-11 fast das erste Mal tatsächlich so ein Movieplot-Szenario dann in der Realität abgespielt worden. Und das führt vielleicht mit zu dieser Situation. Also die Wahrscheinlichkeit eines weiteren 9-11 ist extrem gering. Und weil das so ist, weiß man halt nicht wirklich rational, wo man dort ansetzen könnte. Und deswegen kann man halt jede Maßnahme, die einem irgendwie opportun ist, mit solchen Movieplot-Szenarien dann rechtfertigen.
Genau, das ist ja auch das, was wir in der aktuellen politischen Diskussion auch sehen. Wenn so alle möglichen Szenarien, so Dirty-Bombs hier, Atomexplosionen da. Und was passiert, wenn? Und wir müssen immer, die Bedrohung ist groß.
Zu Dirty-Bombs, wo du sie gerade erwähnst. Also ich habe mir das auch mal angesehen, wie gefährlich denn sogenannte schmutzige Atombomben eigentlich tatsächlich sind. Und wenn man sich anschaut, zu welchen Ergebnissen dort die Experten kommen, stellt man fest, dass die psychologische Bedrohung von Dirty-Bombs wesentlich größer ist als die reale Gefahr. Also selbst wenn mitten in New York jemand eine schmutzige Atombombe zünden würde, handelt es sich zunächst mal nicht wirklich um eine Atombombe, sondern eigentlich um eine konventionelle Bombe, die dann eben radioaktives, strahlendes Material freisetzt. Was aber zu einer Kontamination führt, die aber aller Wahrscheinlichkeit oder nach dem, was man jetzt weiß, recht gut beherrschbar wäre. Also sowohl die Folgen, man hat es durchaus an Tschernobyl gesehen und eine schmutzige Bombe, die irgendwie auch nur annähernd in die Größenordnung von Tschernobyl kommt, was die Freisetzung von Radioaktivität angeht, ist nicht vorstellbar. Also jede schmutzige Bombe würde um Größenordnungen darunter bleiben. Das heißt, was dort wirklich passieren würde beim Zünden einer schmutzigen Bombe, ist, dass wahrscheinlich die meisten Menschen durch die entstehende Panik geschädigt würden. Und man ansonsten ein paar Wochen putzen müsste dort, um die Radioaktivität wieder zu entfernen. Aber tatsächlich wäre objektiv gesehen der Schaden, den man damit anrichten kann.
Wobei schon Leute dabei sterben können, muss man sagen.
Unwahrscheinlich. Also es ist unwahrscheinlich, dass bei Zünden einer schmutzigen Bombe es gelänge, so viel Strahlung freizusetzen. Also natürlich wäre das etwas, was Leute krank machen würde, aber vermutlich nichts im Vergleich zu Salmonellen oder Gammelfleisch, was das potentiell oder einer Grippe. Epidemie, die jedes Jahr kommt, fordert wesentlich mehr Todesopfer als die größte vorstellbare schmutzige Atombombe, mitten in der Großstadt gezündet.
Du meintest, du hast ja gesagt, ist die Eintrittswahrscheinlichkeit sehr gering, dann ignoriert man die Risiken. Das ist nachvollziehbar. Das bedeutet aber auch im Umkehrschluss, dass man ja in der Lage sein muss, die Eintrittswahrscheinlichkeit auch überhaupt kompetent zu bewerten. Man sieht das ja schon in der Diskussion, wie wahrscheinlich ist überhaupt etwas, dass etwas passiert ist. Kann ja so in dem Sinne nicht immer jemand beantworten. Oder selbst wenn man es beantworten könnte, kann der Einzelne es vielleicht nicht unbedingt tun. Gerade jetzt so aus betriebswirtschaftlicher Sicht, was würdest du denn da als die wichtigsten Kompetenzen erachten, die man sich erarbeiten muss, um Eintrittswahrscheinlichkeiten dann auch korrekt bewerten zu können?
Also in dem Fall ist das Einzige, worauf man wirklich sicher bauen kann, ist eine historische Betrachtung, wie ich schon gesagt habe, zu gucken, wie häufig sind bestimmte Dinge denn tatsächlich passiert. Und das ist das Einzige, wo man aus statistischen Betrachtungen heraus ist das Einzige, wo man Eintrittswahrscheinlichkeiten für bekannte Gefahren oder Bedrohungen, die unverändert schon eine gewisse Zeit existieren, dann schätzen kann. Ich würde behaupten, bei unbekannten oder neuen Gefahren oder Bedrohungen ist es schlichtweg kaum möglich, die Eintrittswahrscheinlichkeit mit der Genauigkeit, die ein Mathematiker oder Informatiker gerne gesehen hätte, zu messen. Aber betriebswirtschaftlich reicht es aus, weil in der Betriebswirtschaft wird meistens bei oder sehr häufig bei solchen Quantifizierungen werden nur drei Werte, nämlich gering, mittel und hoch, verwendet. Und das reicht aber für viele Zwecke auch schon aus, indem man tatsächlich auf dieser Skala gering, mittel, hoch zum Beispiel die Dinge bewertet. Und da kann man zumindest, ich meine, reicht es um...
Die drei Worte kann man natürlich nicht in eine mathematische Formel einsetzen, da braucht man schon eine Zahl.
Das kommt halt immer darauf an. Die Welt ist nun mal so komplex, die entzieht sich gelegentlich auch. Oder in der Regel so einfachen Versuchen, die Dinge für die Zukunft zu quantisieren. Wie gesagt, für die Vergangenheit kann man das statistisch schon tun. Aber ansonsten für die Zukunft scheint es nicht mal möglich zu sein, in Berlin vorherzusagen, wie viele Kinder in sechs Jahren eingeschult werden. Obwohl man meinen müsste, dass das theoretisch zumindest möglich sein müsste. Aber das ist jetzt ein anderer Sicherheitsbereich. Aber vielleicht noch um das Thema jetzt aus betriebswirtschaftlicher Sicht noch mal mehr abzuschließen. Wenn Sicherheitsmaßnahmen, das ist auch eine traurige Erfahrung, die man machen muss, wenn man so gerade im Bereich Sicherheit arbeitet, dass die erfolgreichen Sicherheitsmaßnahmen meistens unbemerkt bleiben. Also, ja, dass nichts passiert, dafür wird man nichts passiert ist, dafür wird einem selten auf die Schultern geklopft und das wird vielleicht am Rande bemerkt. Aber eigentlich ist es halt unspektakulär. Wenn nichts passiert, passiert nichts.
Kann ja auch sein, dass das gar keine richtige Bedrohung ist.
Genau, darüber redet man dann halt nicht. Man hat vielleicht auch Glück gehabt, man weiß es nicht. Es ist halt nichts passiert und deswegen lohnt es sich auch nicht, darüber zu reden, während ein Versagen ganz stark wahrgenommen wird. Und klar, da ist was passiert, das hätte nicht passieren dürfen und sollen und warum und wer ist schuld. Und dann wird ein unglaublicher Wind gemacht und dann als Reaktion man nie wieder und dann wird eben bei katastrophalem Versagen tatsächlich reagiert und Sicherheitsmaßnahmen getroffen und erhöht. Dann aber eben oft exzessiv. Das heißt, man versucht dann auch so ein bisschen die Schuld, die man vielleicht trägt, dafür, dass das jetzt so schlimm gekommen ist, ein wenig zu kompensieren, indem man dafür jetzt so richtig mit dem Sicherheitshammer draufhaut und dabei aber sehr häufig dann über das Ziel dann hinausschießt. Und das ist das, was wir vermutlich auch beobachten können. Ganz klar bei der jetzt in einen anderen Bereich wechseln mit den Flüssigkeitsverboten, etwa die in der EU eingeführt worden sind.
Du meinst jetzt am Flughafen, dass man nur noch bis 100 Milliliter Flüssigkeiten überhaupt mitnehmen darf und die dann auch noch in so einem affigen Plastebeutel, transparenten Plastebeutel tragen muss?
Genau, und einzelne Behälter nur mit 100 Milliliter maximal und in dem transparenten Beutel. Genau, und das ist so ein sehr gutes Beispiel für dann ja exzessive, für Exzessives über das Ziel hinausschießen beispielsweise.
Du sagtest ja vorhin, Flugsicherheit könnte ja auch noch mal ein Thema werden. Hast du dir da denn besondere Gedanken gemacht? Das ist ja wirklich so ein Fall. Flughäfen scheinen immer so der Ort zu sein, wo Sicherheitsmaßnahmen auch gleich als erstes gemacht durchgeführt werden. Irgendwie ist das Transportmittel Flugzeug erscheint allen besonders schützenswert, was ja eigentlich Blödsinn ist, weil wenn man jetzt mal rein von den Zahlen ausgeht, wenn natürlich sehr viel mehr in Autos und Zügen gereist als jetzt in Flugzeugen. Hast du da eine Erklärung dafür, warum ausgerechnet das so?
Ja, dafür gibt es ganz gute Erklärungen. Also erstmal ist natürlich ein Flugzeug speziell im Flug doch eine recht fragile Geschichte. Und dazu kommt noch so etwas wie Höhenangst in dem Fall sicherlich zurecht. Also wir Menschen sind eigentlich eher zweieinhalbdimensionale Menschen. Also etwas in zehn Meter Entfernung wird ganz anders wahrgenommen, als wenn ich in zehn Meter Höhe irgendwo hinunterschaue. Also Höhe ist für uns nochmal eine ganz andere Dimension, weil ja klar, also auch ein Sturz aus zehn Meter Höhe ist einfach was anderes als zehn Meter weit zu laufen. Insofern ist es sicherlich nachvollziehbar. Was jetzt aber speziell dazu kommt, Flugzeuge. Fliegen war früher sehr teuer und damit waren Flugzeuge früher das Transportmittel der Elite und entwickelten sich natürlich deswegen wiederum zum begehrten Angriffsziel, hauptsächlich für den palästinensischen Terrorismus. Wobei generell natürlich man mit Flugzeugen außerdem noch eine Beweglichkeit hat. Das heißt als Entführer hat man dann auch noch einen taktischen Vorteil, wenn man das Flugzeug in seine Gewalt gebracht hat, indem man dann eventuell sich auch der Verfolgung entziehen kann, indem man dann einfach in ein anderes Land damit fliegt. Also Kuba, USA war ja auch beliebt. Es gab ja diesen berühmten Witz seinerzeit, als ständig Flugzeuge von den USA nach Kuba entführt wurden. Steigt jemand in eine Straßenbahn und hält dem Schaffner eine Pistole an den Kopf und sagt es nach Kuba?
Wann sind denn so viele entführt worden? Ist das so eine Welle?
Ja, es gibt da Statistiken, ich habe sie genau nicht mehr im Kopf, aber in Spitzenzeiten waren das, glaube ich, so etwas wie 30 Flüge pro Jahr, die nach Kuba entführt worden sind. Also es ist eine große Zeit. Im Übrigen hat sich interessanterweise die Zahl der Flugzeugentführungen insgesamt in den letzten 30 Jahren aber nicht unwesentlich verändert. Auch seit 9-11 werden nicht weniger Flugzeuge entführt. Allerdings finden die Entführungen jetzt meistens in anderen Teilen der Welt statt und deswegen kriegt man davon nicht so viel mit. Also in Europa und in den USA oder generell in der westlichen Welt ist es tatsächlich seltener geworden. Aber so in Indien oder in russischen Republiken oder in Südamerika passiert das auch nach wie vor mit einer gewissen Häufigkeit. Ich glaube auch in der Wikipedia gibt es irgendwo nette Statistiken dazu.
Im Artikel Flugzeugentführung kann man da einiges zu nachlesen.
Ja, also Grund dafür eben zusammengefasst, Verkehrsmittel der Elite, taktische Beweglichkeit und seit 9-11 kommt auch noch der Faktor Zerstörungskraft hinzu, weil mit der kinetischen Energie und den Treibstoffmengen an Bord stellt sein Flugzeug auch noch eine effektive Bombe dar. Also insofern ist das sicherlich schon gerechtfertigt, dass man aufpassen muss, also mehr aufpassen muss als an anderen Stellen.
Und hilft das jetzt alles, was an Sicherheitsmaßnahmen gegriffen wurde?
Also es hilft nicht wirklich vor entschlossenen, also eine Gruppe entschlossener und gut ausgebildeter Terroristen hätte nach wie vor keine großen Probleme ein Luftfahrzeug in seine Gewalt zu bringen.
Was macht sie da so sicher?
Weil es einfach keine Möglichkeit gibt, also die einzige Möglichkeit wirklich das Ausschließen zu wollen wäre, indem man niemanden mehr mitfliegen lässt. Ansonsten, oder die Leute halt nackt und mit Handschellen gefesselt oder betäubt transportiert, aber selbst das würde nicht ausreichen, also eigentlich dürfte niemand mitfliegen. Dann, ja, aber selbst dann gäbe es noch Möglichkeiten, ja, und wenn man, also ich bin mir auch sicher, dass jeder halbwegs fähige Geheimdienst auch problemlos in der Lage wäre, jede Menge Waffen in der benötigten Form ins Flugzeug zu bringen. Und da gibt es so viele Punkte, die man nicht absichern kann. Ich meine, wir haben an einem Großflughafen Frankfurt gehen 70.000 Mitarbeiter ein und aus, und die müssen da auch ein und ausgehen. Und auf der anderen Seite, wenn man sich Passagiere, Passagiersicherheit anguckt, ist das mittlerweile fast das geringste Problem. Aber selbst dort, wenn ich ja wirklich Dinge durch die Kontrolle schleusen will, gefährliche Dinge, kann ich die so gestalten, dass die nicht erkannt werden.
Als Passagier meinst du?
Als Passagier, genau. Mit ein wenig Fantasie. Ja, ist das problemlos möglich. Aber was man aber auch sehen muss, ist, dass wahrscheinlich 99,999999% aller Passagiere, die fliegen, einfach keine Bedrohung des Luftverkehrs darstellen.
Die Eintrittswahrscheinlichkeit ist gering.
Ja, die Eintrittswahrscheinlichkeit ist eher gering und was mich an 9-Eleven damals gewundert hat, komplizierte Pläne laufen selten so wie geplant. Also das fand ich mit das Erstaunlichste, dass halt dieser doch relativ komplizierte Plan, den die dort abgezogen hat, auch funktioniert. Also ich würde sagen, selbst wenn ein Geheimdienst eine solche Operation plant, wobei vermutlich irgendeine Form von Geheimdienst dort die Finger auch mit drin gehabt hat. Ja selbst da ist die Eintritts-, also die Erfolgsaussichten eher gering, also bei so komplizierten Plänen. Und also mit, jetzt um das nochmal klarzustellen, mit Geheimdienst die Finger drin, damit meine ich, dass die Leute, die das Ganze ausgeführt haben, direkt oder indirekt auf Know-how, was in irgendwo auf der Welt im Rahmen von geheimdienstlichen Aktivitäten erdacht wurde und aufgeschrieben und weiter transportiert wurde, sei es, indem die CIA Osama bin Laden und seine Leute ausgebildet hat und ihnen ein paar Dinge verraten hat, wie man denn am besten gegen die Sowjets vorgeht. Das heißt, da hat sicherlich, also 9-11 ist sicherlich auch durch eine zumindest durch eine Proliferation von Geheimdienstwissen zustande gekommen. Das heißt, es gibt mit Sicherheit eine indirekte Verantwortung von Geheimdiensten für diesen Anschlag.
Okay, aber wir wollen uns ja jetzt hier nicht in dem Verschwörungsmischmasch 9-11 zu sehr beteiligen, sondern doch eigentlich eher ein bisschen um die Sicherheitsaspekte als solche zu sprechen kommen. Wenn ich mal so ein bisschen zusammenfassen darf, wir hatten jetzt vor allem so eben so die Rentabilität von Sicherheit im Auge, also vor allem jetzt was mache ich als Firma, um Sicherheitsmaßnahmen überhaupt richtig zu bemessen. Das ist sicherlich schwierig. Ich weiß nicht, hast du da noch ein paar Ratschläge, wie man am besten vorgehen soll? Also die Stolperfallen haben wir ja jetzt schon ganz gut aufgezählt, aber was wäre sozusagen der richtige Schritt?
Also generell denke ich, als generellen Ratschlag, den psychologischen Fallstricken widerstehen. Das heißt, wenn was passiert ist, gucken, dass man nicht exzessiv reagiert und im Vorfeld zu gucken, wie sehen die Bedrohungen eigentlich aus und dort dann im Vorfeld angemessen, dem Grad der Gefährdung entsprechend Vorsorge zu leisten und dann eben auch auf keinen Fall alles auf eine Karte zu setzen. Auch in der Sicherheit gibt es keine Silver Bullet, sondern auch da einen Bündel von vernünftigen Maßnahmen zu sagen. Es macht auch vor allem keinen Sinn, an einer Stelle zu übertreiben. Also, was weiß ich, mir irgendwo gigantische Firewalls und beispielsweise, wenn ich meine Rechner sichern will, dort vorzusehen, während und gleichzeitig etwa die physikalische Sicherheit zu vernachlässigen und so, dass eventuell die Putzleute Zutritt zum Rechnerraum haben und dort alles mitnehmen können oder die Türschlösser zu schwach sind und bei einem Einbruch alles mitgenommen wird. Das heißt, man muss tatsächlich gucken, also wo sind die größten Risiken? Und das ist definitiv, wenn man sich anschaut, ganz klassisch Einbruch, Feuer, Überschwemmung zu sehen, jetzt sowohl privat als auch als Unternehmen. Denn privat als Bedrohung ist immer noch der Straßenverkehr die größte Gefahr für Leib und Leben.
Wenn du jetzt nicht einer Firma, sondern einem Innenminister der Bundesrepublik Deutschland einen Ratschlag geben solltest, wie er seine Sicherheitsmaßnahmen verteilen sollte, was würde dir da dann einfallen?
Na ja, da müssen wir vielleicht, also vielleicht gehen wir dann das Thema nochmal Sicherheit aus politischer Sicht an. Da haben wir schon gesagt, totale Sicherheit ist unmöglich und diesen Anschein sollte man auch gar nicht erwecken.
Das ist wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal wünschenswert.
Und es gibt halt eben bestimmte Formen von Sicherheit, für die ist der Staat derzeit und auf absehbare Zeit hin der einzige und unentbehrliche Garant. Sagt äußere Sicherheit etwa oder bestimmte Formen von Schwerstkriminalität, organisierte Kriminalität etwa, da denke ich, da sehe ich ganz reale Gefahren. Da sind auch reale Gefahren für den Staat, wenn etwa Beamte korrumpiert werden. Oder wenn wir nach Sachsen gucken, wo wirklich recht hohe staatliche Vertreter und Organe in Richter, Politiker, Polizeibeamte, in kriminelle Machenschaften verwickelt waren. Oder allein das Thema, ich hab gesehen, dass doch ein sehr großer Prozentsatz, der Politiker auch in irgendeiner Form sich auffällig geworden ist, sodass sie in verschiedene Strafverfahren verwickelt waren, sei es aufgrund von Parteifinanzierung, Spenden, Geschichten, viele andere Dinge, wo sich auch verstrickt haben. Insofern, das ist auf jeden Fall auch eine Richtung, wo ich reale Gefahren sehe, tatsächlich für die innere Sicherheit. Und schon gesagt, es gibt einen sehr großen Unterschied zwischen gefühlter und realer Sicherheit. Und als Politiker ist man offenbar, oder viele Politiker sind weniger um die gefühlte Sicherheit, um die reale Sicherheit besorgt, als vielmehr um die gefühlte Sicherheit. Weil die reale Sicherheit ist schwer zu vermitteln. Das ist langweiliges Zeug. Das sind irgendwelche Statistiken. Und dass wir irgendwie wieder irgendwo tausend Unfalltote weniger haben. Damit kann man offenbar politisch nicht viele Punkte machen. Das setzen wir auch als selbstverständlich raus. Während man sich sehr doch auf die gefühlte Sicherheit konzentriert.
Und vor allem auch auf die gefühlte Bedrohung. Also man hat das jetzt neulich wieder so, ja die Kriminalitätsstatistiken werden vorgestellt. Und es zeigt sich, wir haben Rückgänge überall. Weitgehend, ich hab mir jetzt nicht alles durchgelesen. Der Trend generell ist ja derzeit nicht wirklich beunruhigend. Also es gibt an sich weniger Kriminalfälle. Es gibt dann Steigerungen bei schweren Straftaten hier und da, aber nichts, was einen jetzt wirklich aus der Bahn werfen sollte. Und das ist so die Argumentation danach so, ja ja, wir sind ja jetzt schon der sicherste Staat. Jetzt müssen wir auch dafür sorgen, dass das so bleibt, denn die Bedrohung ist ja größer geworden. Bloß diese Bedrohung steht ja nicht drin in diesem Papier, in diesen Zahlen.
Genau, das ist natürlich auch ein psychologischer Effekt, dass je weniger tatsächlich passiert, so je luxuriöser wir uns, also je vermeintlich, oder je unsicherer wir tatsächlich sind, umso mehr sind natürlich, wenn dann tatsächlich was passiert, sind wir es einfach nicht gewöhnt und die Angst steigt halt offenbar überproportional, wenn die tatsächliche Bedrohung zurückgeht. So, weil diese Bedrohungen oder Gefahren dann viel abstrakter sind. Und das hat sich auch, also als ich in New York war etwa, hat sich das auch sehr schön gezeigt, dass die New Yorker nach 9-11 relativ schnell wieder zur Tagesordnung übergegangen sind. Also die waren dann irgendwann, haben sich nur gewundert über die ganzen Gäste, die dann immer kamen und fragten, und wie fühlt ihr euch? Habt ihr nicht irgendwie Angst? Ist es nicht gefährlich? Und man hat dann festgestellt, dass die Leute in New York durchweg weniger Angst vor einem Terroranschlag hatten, als der Großteil der Bevölkerung, die irgendwo auf dem Land lebte und nur aus dem Fernsehen davon gehört hat. Die fühlten sich wesentlich gefährderter, als tatsächlich die New Yorker, die nun nun mittendrin standen. Insofern ist da wahrscheinlich auch der Aspekt, dass je sicherer wir werden, umso einfacher ist es, uns Angst einzujagen.
Mich erinnert mich an so ein, ich weiß nicht von wem, das war Klaus Steck, der meinte so in Richtung die SPD, so Genossen, die CDU möchte euch eure Willen im Tessin wegnehmen. Ja, wer viel hat, hat viel zu verlieren.
Ja, das ist natürlich auch das Ding. Also wir sind es gewohnt. Ich meine, gut, nicht dass man dahin zurück will, aber vor 100 Jahren war man es gewohnt, dass, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht noch ein Drittel der Kinder, die geboren wurden, einfach durch Lebensrisiken, vor allem Krankheiten, natürlich auch andere Dinge, Infektionen, einfach gestorben sind. Und heute sieht es halt eben anders aus. Also Unglücke oder Unfälle oder Tod ist etwas, was so selten geworden ist, dass es als riesige Bedrohung wahrgenommen wird. Das ist das Ding. Und wenn man jetzt noch mal auf den Staat blickt, muss man sehen, dass heutzutage ein entwickelter Industriestaat einfach über extreme Macht und Mittel verfügt. In Form nicht nur von Armeen und Waffen, sondern auch ganzen wissenschaftlichen Möglichkeiten, die es gibt und auch mittlerweile professionelle Kenntnisse, wie Menschen dazu gebracht werden, etwas zu tun oder nicht zu tun. Wobei das nicht nur auf Staaten beschränkt ist, sondern da natürlich auch große Unternehmen oder generell so Machtkonglomerate einfach den sehr vielen Mitteln zur Verfügung stehen. Aber der Staat ist trotzdem noch was Besonderes, weil dort eigentlich ein gewisses Gewaltmonopol sein sollte. Aber wenn man jetzt etwa aktuell die Diskussion oder anguckt, wie viel Privatisierung jetzt im Irakkrieg mittlerweile betrieben wurde und wie jetzt etwa der aktuelle Blackwater-Skandal man sich anschaut, wie dort auch private Organisationen jetzt Waffengewalt ausüben.
Nicht nur im Irak, also das war ja auch schon in New Orleans nicht anders, dass die sogenannte öffentliche Sicherheit da weitgehend von Blackwater hergestellt wurde. Beziehungsweise überhaupt eigentlich Sicherheit nur dort existierte, wo Leute sich eben Privatarminen privaten Sicherheitsschutz leisten konnten.
Aber meine zentrale These ist jetzt, wenn so ein Staat in falsche Hände gerät, beispielsweise, sind eben die Auswirkungen einfach potenziell verheerend. Das heißt, während der Staat einerseits der einzige und größte Garant von Sicherheit in sehr vielen Bereichen ist, ist er auch die größte potenzielle Bedrohung für die Sicherheit des Einzelnen aufgrund dieser Wachtmittel. Das heißt, da muss man eben dann schon sehr genau hinschauen. Wo gibt es eben Punkte? Und gerade, wenn man sich natürlich die deutsche Geschichte anguckt, dann weiß man, was das bedeutet, wenn ein Staat in falsche Hände gerät, dann sind die Auswirkungen einfach weltweit und in Ausmaßen und betreffend das Leben potentiell jedes einzelnen in einer Art und Weise, wie das möglicherweise nur Naturkatastrophen oder nicht mal Naturkatastrophen, sondern eher schon, da muss man schon fast kosmische Katastrophen hinzunehmen, die ja ähnliche Verheerungen anrichten können, wie jetzt Staaten. Insofern ist natürlich auch, wüsste man den Begriff vielleicht Staatssicherheit, auch aus einer anderen, also wie sicher ist mein Staat dagegen, dass er mir, dass er dem Individuum Schaden zufügt. Und in Deutschland sind nun aus schlechten Erfahrungen sehr viele Sicherungen eingebaut worden dort. Aber eine Sicherung nach der anderen wird halt natürlich weggesprengt. Und gerade da natürlich auch viele Maßnahmen, wo man eben auch aufpassen muss, mit denen man vermeintlich Sicherheit schafft, schaffen unter Umständen neue Unsicherheiten. Also etwa bestimmte Datensammlungen. Ist ja ganz schön und gut, so dass jetzt Abhörmöglichkeiten und Datensammlungen da sind. Und das wäre auch völlig unproblematisch, wenn man davon ausgehen könnte, dass die Individuen, die dort im staatlichen Auftrag arbeiten, alle 100 Prozent vertrauenswürdig sind und einfach perfekte Menschen, die keinerlei Versuchungen erliegen und selber nie auf die Idee kommen würden, irgendwelche bösen Dinge zu tun. So dann wäre das relativ unproblematisch. Da ich aber weiß, dass sich der Staat und die Politik eben nicht aus solchen reinen Übermenschen rekrutiert, ist relativ klar, aus langer Sicht betrachtet. Und solche Datensammlungen existieren natürlich nicht nur kurzfristig, sondern Sachen, die jetzt geschaffen werden, können 10, 50, 100, sonst wie Jahre Bestand haben. Und wenn man mal jetzt wieder auf das Thema Eintrittswahrscheinlichkeit kommt und selbst eine geringe Eintrittswahrscheinlichkeit, das hat natürlich auch was mit Zeit zu tun über einen langen Zeitraum hinweg, so wird dann, also erhöht sich natürlich die Eintrittswahrscheinlichkeit. Das heißt, selbst wenn es jetzt sehr unwahrscheinlich ist, dass etwa mit dieser Datensammlung irgendwie im nächsten oder im übernächsten Jahr oder in den nächsten fünf Jahren jemand was Böses tun wird, kann man umgekehrt sagen, es ist so gut wie sicher, dass in den nächsten 50 oder 100 Jahren irgendwann ziemlich übler Missbrauch damit betrieben werden wird. Oder dass vielleicht sogar im Rahmen äußerer Sicherheit Agenten, chinesische Hacker, sich dieser Daten bemächtigen und Leute, also man schafft mit bestimmten, man schafft ein Missbrauchspotenzial, man schafft Gefahren, man schafft neue Gefahren und man schafft unter dem Strich einfach weniger Sicherheit. So für alle, weniger Sicherheit für den Staat, weniger Sicherheit für die Individuen, weil er eben, weil eben neue Angriffspunkte geschaffen werden. Und ja, das ist das eigentliche Problem neben natürlich dem Thema Freiheit und Menschenwürde, wo viele dieser Maßnahmen doch nicht gerade zu Gunsten dieser Werte offenbar verlaufen.
Diese Datensammlungen sind natürlich ein besonders heißes Ding, auch wenn man da wieder einmal so zurückgeht in der Geschichte. So die ersten Holleried-Lochkartensysteme, die zur Einwohnererfassung verwendet wurden, waren natürlich dann auch ein super Datenbank später, um dann die Judenverfolgung auch wirklich professionell rauszunehmen. Und eben auch so dieses, was du schon meintest, mit Sicherheitssysteme, die wir insbesondere der Bundesrepublik haben, so diese Trennung zwischen Polizei und Geheimdiensten, die dann teilweise auch schon wieder aufgehoben werden sollen, weil die ja im Prinzip einen Informationsaustausch, Blockade schafft, öffnet dann eben diesen neuen Datenbanken, die jetzt immer umfangreicher werden und jetzt auch noch mit biometrischen Merkmalen versehen sind, natürlich dann auch den mehr oder weniger uneingeschränkten Fluss innerhalb des Staatsgebildes, das ziemlich groß ist. Wie viele Leute arbeiten denn in diesem Staat?
Also zumindest, wenn man mal sich die Staatsquote anschaut, die bei ungefähr 50 Prozent liegt, ist es so, dass zumindest die Hälfte unseres Geldkreislaufs so durch staatliche Hände geht. Das heißt nicht, dass die Hälfte jetzt der Leute beschäftigt sind, aber zunächst mal also die Hälfte der Ressourcen gehen durch staatliche Hände. Davon sind natürlich eine ganze Menge Sozialleistungen. Also es werden, ich habe jetzt keine Zahl parat, du wirst sicherlich gleich eine finden, aber meine Schätzung wäre, dass es sich um einige Millionen handelt. Also dass sich so die Zahl der Staatsbediensteten und beim Staat Angestellten irgendwo...
Also die Staatsquote besteht sicher nicht auf Personen, sondern auf die Gesamteistung der Wirtschaft. Also 2005 war es in Deutschland 46,8 Prozent, wobei sie sinkt im Oehring, zumindest in den letzten zwei, drei Jahren.
Und...
Also auf jeden Fall verdammt viele Leute sind in irgendeiner Form direkt oder indirekt im Staatssystem beschäftigt.
Aber was man natürlich auch aber sagen muss, es gibt natürlich auch noch eine ganz andere Realität. So wenn man einerseits wird, werden jetzt punktuell Dinge ausgebaut und vorangetrieben Gesetze werden verschärft, Datensammlungen. Also einerseits gibt es ein Repressionsmechanismus. Auf der anderen Seite wurden bundesweit in den letzten Jahren 10.000 Polizeistellen abgebaut. Teilweise der Zustand von polizeilicher Präsenz auf dem Land ist teilweise erbarmlich. Ich hab mir sagen lassen, dass es in einigen östlichen Bundesländern die Hälfte aller Verfolgungsjagden durch die Polizei daran scheitert, dass ihnen der Sprit ausgeht oder die Beamten Feierabend haben.
Also künftig um 18 Uhr wird dann auf die Bremse getreten.
Naja, es gibt halt natürlich nicht jetzt, wenn Gefahr im Verzug ist, aber wenn irgendwie eine Observation beispielsweise stattfindet und es ist Feierabend, dann wird es halt einfach abgebrochen. Klar. Und die Polizei schiebt riesige Mengen an Überstunden vor sich hieran. Eigentlich heißt es ja auch, wenn man wirklich wissen will, was die Politik im Schilde führt, muss man sich den Haushalt anschauen. Also wofür wird tatsächlich Geld ausgegeben und nicht was wird jetzt ansonsten getan? Und da sieht es eher so aus, dass an vielen Stellen tatsächlich an innerer Sicherheit eher gespart wird bzw. die Kosten vom Staat weg auf die Bürger verlagert werden, indem neue Gesetze zur Erhöhung der Sicherheit wie jetzt auch die ganzen Abhörmaßnahmen, die zahlt ja nicht der Staat, also die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, sondern die Kosten, dafür werden auf die Provider und damit auf die Kunden abgewälzt. Das heißt, man muss jetzt für seine eigene Überwachung auch noch zahlen, wobei es wahrscheinlich egal ist, ob man das über Steuermittel tut. Aber dann, wenn es über Steuern ginge, wäre der Druck nochmal sicherlich ein ganz anderer, diese wiederum im Rahmen des Haushalts bereitzustellen. So macht man einfach ein Gesetz, das ist in Teilen so perfide. Es ist zwar eine andere Kategorie, aber es erinnert mich daran, dass in bestimmten Regimen die Kosten für die Kugel, mit denen der Verurteilte erschossen wurde, der Familie dann noch in Rechnung gestellt wurden.
Das erinnert mich fatal an meinen Lieblingsfilm Brasil, wo es auch diese schöne Stelle gibt, wo er sagt, das war bestimmt Simmons, der war schon immer der Meinung, dass die Leute mehr für ihre Verhöre bezahlen sollen. Und wo auch diese ganze Absurdität ist, so dass man, während man eigentlich nur noch ins Gefängnis geschmissen wird, vorgerechnet bekommt, wie viel man diesen Staat gekostet hat. Ich denke, das ist auch so ein Problem in der Denke, dass man so gar nicht, dass die meisten Leute überhaupt nicht mehr den Staat verstehen als etwas, was eigentlich eine Dienstleistung für die Gesellschaft bieten soll und quasi die Bürger ist, sondern dass es so dieses, diese anderen, genau, da draußen, die Beamten, die da oben, die Politiker, die ja sowieso machen, was sie wollen und aus dieser Grundhaltung heraus das dann wahrscheinlich auch tun irgendwann. Was ist denn jetzt deine Empfehlung für den Innenminister generell?
Zurücktreten.
Nein, ich meine, was er tun sollte. Ich meine, wenn du jetzt Innenminister wärst, würdest du dann auch gleich zurücktreten.
Ja, ich meine, also erst mal Politiker zu sein, ist, glaube ich, alles andere als ein einfacher Job. Keine Frage. Und deswegen war das Zurücktreten auch dahin, also in die Richtung gemeint. Ich habe nicht das Gefühl, dass er sich und anderen einen gefallen tut, indem er so weitermacht, wie er da bisher agiert.
Also, was ich auch aus …Was ist den aktuellen, ganz konkreten Innenminister?
Ja, den ganz konkreten Innenminister. Und ich habe doch aus verschiedenen Quellen von Leuten, die nun in direkten Kontakt mit ihm stehen, die ihn also so in seiner Lebenswirklichkeit und so aus erster Hand agieren sehen, haben also durchaus meinen Eindruck bestätigt, dass er in vielen Situationen in hohem Maße irrational und schizophren agiert, dass er einerseits etwa in einer Sitzung mehr Sicherheit und mehr Kontrollen an Flughäfen fordert, um sich anschließend, wenn er dann in den Flieger steigt und es dort nicht schnell genug vorangeht, sich massiv darüber eschoffiert, warum das jetzt so lange dauert und was das hier für ein Chaos ist. Also so auch wirklich, der offenbar die abstrakten Entscheidungen, die er trifft mit der Lebenswirklichkeit, nicht so richtig in der Lage ist, in Einklang zu bringen. Und insofern gründet sich meine Empfehlung für den aktuellen Innenminister erst mal darauf. Er sollte vielleicht einen anderen, interessanteren Job finden. Es gibt sicherlich in dem ganzen Politbereich, also er muss sich ja nicht zur Ruhe setzen, aber es gibt einfach bestimmt passendere Jobs, wo er vielleicht wirklich seine Fähigkeiten, seine Talente, ich meine, er ist ein super intelligenter Mann, auch mit extremem Weitblick und Tiefgang und historischem Verständnis, aber er ist da einfach an der falschen Stelle.
Gut, aber ich wollte ja nicht so sehr auf Schäuble mich konzentrieren, sondern eher so dieses sowas, was sollte der Ansatz sein, Sicherheit zu gestalten und vielleicht kann man ja auch da ruhig noch mal ein bisschen auf die Metaebene zurückgehen. Ich weiß nicht, ob du jetzt noch ein, zwei, drei Ausführungen hast, die du unbedingt unterbringen möchtest, weil wir auch langsam zum Ende kommen sollten.
Gut, es kommt immer drauf an, an welcher Ebene. Ich habe jetzt noch keinen Innenminister-Posten angeboten bekommen, deswegen habe ich mir konkret darüber noch keine großen Gedanken gemacht, aber gut, gehen wir mal. Gut, nehmen wir mal an, okay, ich wäre jetzt Innenminister. Was würde ich tun? Also ich würde erst mal mich um mein Personal kümmern. Also ich würde erst mal gucken, dass ich dort gute, fitte Leute habe, die für mich arbeiten, die den Job tun. Würde gucken, dass die Leute ein bisschen besser bezahlt werden und einfach erst mal eine gute Stimmung im Sicherheitsapparat herrscht. Nein, nein, es ist einfach nur so, dass Leute, die einfach angenehmere Arbeitsbedingungen haben, einfach leistungsfähiger sind. Und dann, ja, gut, dann würde ich zunächst mal gucken, dass von allen Maßnahmen, die ich eventuell durchführe, würde ich schauen, kann man den Nutzen davon, ist der in irgendeiner Weise messbar und würde halt alle Schritte, die ich ergreife, regelmäßig auf den Prüfstand stellen und beispielsweise alle Gesetze, die ich etwa verabschiede, mit einem Verfallsdatum versehen, wo sie automatisch wieder ungültig werden und sämtliche Datensammlungen würde ich erstmal, also wenn ich welche anliegen würde, einfach auch terminieren und ganz klar sagen, okay, das kommt auch irgendwann weg, weil die Zeiten ändern sich unter Umständen und würde halt zum einen Gelegenheit geben, nicht jetzt irgendwelche Entscheidungen zu treffen, die nicht mehr rückgängig zu machen sind, weil was man auch sehen muss, man sieht es ja im Internet, Daten, die einmal ins Internet gelangt sind, Ich glaube, die anderen, die mir schon angeschränkt sind, sind nicht mehr zurückzuholen. Ich würde also versuchen zu vermeiden, Dinge zu tun, die irreversibel sind. Gut, konkret jetzt auf innere Sicherheit bezogen, würde ich einer zum einen vermeiden, Leute allzu sehr zu provozieren, würde auf der anderen Seite gut, gibt es immer irgendwelche, ich sag mal, Spinner oder Leute, die so extrem unterwegs sind, dass sie von nichts zurückschrecken. Und da würde ich dann schon auch als Innenminister natürlich dafür sorgen, dass es einen Apparat gibt, der dort zielgerichtet dafür sorgt, dass das reale Gefahren abgewendet wird.
Aber das sagen ja alle. Also das ist ja noch nichts, wenn du jetzt gewählt werden willst.
Na ja, mit dem Ziel gerichtet. Also wie gesagt, ich will nicht gewählt werden, weil ich glaube, ich eignet mich auch nicht zum Politiker und dazu. Also ich würde vielleicht gucken, was sich so aus dem Artikel 1 unserer Verfassung so als Handlungsauftrag ergibt. Und das ist halt einfach der Schutz der Menschenwürde. Und darauf würde ich mich fokussieren.
Okay, ich werde das nicht weiter vertiefen. Haben wir denn jetzt noch was, was wir auf jeden Fall noch beleuchten sollten? Ein langer Marsch. Wir haben jetzt hier fast zwei Stunden durch. Ich denke, weiter können wir unsere Hymne nicht strapazieren.
So langsam macht sich auch ein wenig Ermüdung breit. Frage wäre noch, was mit dem ganzen Biometriezeugs eigentlich, was jetzt auf dem Vormarsch ist, was denn da nun dahinter steckt. Und gestern, gerade gestern fiel mir noch ein, was ein möglicher, wirklicher Grund für die Einführung dieser ganzen Biometrie sein könnte. Nämlich, wie in vielen Fällen, so auf lange Sicht Kosten sparen zu wollen. Indem man nämlich noch mehr Polizei abbaut und die Personenkontrollen vielleicht die Vision hat, die dann mehr und mehr Maschinen zu übertragen. Oder ich meine, im Moment, wenn man jemanden an der Grenze sitzen hat, der halt Personen kontrolliert, dann muss man den noch ausbilden. Und so im Bilder vergleichen und auf Verdachtsmomente achten. Und möglicherweise ist ja die Vision, dass wenn wir alle verbiometrisiert sind, dann reicht es, wenn dort eine Hartz IV oder ein Euro-Jobber sitzt und der an der Grenze und der Rest halt durch Finger auflegen auf einen Scanner passiert und dann geht die Schranke auf. Und dann gibt es irgendwo noch hinten zwei, drei Mann, die im Notfall vielleicht intervenieren. Dieser Gedanke kam mir gestern, ob das nicht in Wirklichkeit hinter der ganzen Biometrie steckt, dass man eigentlich Kosten reduzieren möchte.
Kosten reduzieren schon, aber zu Lasten der Sicherheit. Zu Lasten der Sicherheit, natürlich aber auch mit der Intention, einfach auch mehr Kontrollen durchführen zu können, weil sie dann, wenn sie schneller und billiger sind, das zu machen. Aber ob wirklich mehr Kontrollen zu mehr Sicherheit führen, ich habe da so meine Zweifel.
Ja, war das jetzt schon das Schlusswort?
Wenn du noch ein anderes Schlusswort hast, kannst du es ja jetzt noch geschwind einwerfen.
Ja, nein.
Nein, kein weiteres Schlusswort. Dann haben wir unser Schlusswort gefunden. Das war Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe 46. Tim Pritlove am Apparat und Pavel mit dabei. Und wir haben uns über Sicherheit unterhalten. Und ich hoffe, das hat alles eure, ist bei euch auf Interesse gestoßen. Demnächst geht es wieder weiter mit Chaosradio Express.